[Musique]
compte 365 plages une pour chaque jour
de l'année
fais attention aux oiseaux
et professeur de kitesurf sur la plage
de jaberwock au nord de l'île cela fait
20 ans qu'il travaille ici on pourrait
dire que j'ai grandi sur cette plage
j'ai vu beaucoup de changements
l'érosion causé par les tempêtes et
aussi regarder vous avez beaucoup de
sable qui récupéré sur cette plage dans
le monde 50 milliards de tonnes de sable
seraient extraites chaque année pour
alimenter l'industrie de la construction
le sable et la deuxième ressource la
plus exploitée après l'eau
le sable semble être une ressource
inépuisable
pour réaliser des petits travaux de
construction la population se sert
directement sur les plages
c'est un petit échelle mais c'est
constant vous savez tous les jours des
gens viennent prennent un ou deux sauts
et petit à petit ça détruit tous les
chemins beaucoup de gens ici pensent que
c'est pas grave de prendre du sac de la
plage les plages sont essentielles pour
protéger les côtes de l'érosion de la
montée des eaux et des cyclones de plus
en plus violents
depuis les années 70 il est interdit
d'extraire du sable bonjour les gars
vous allez bien une patrouille du
gouvernement surveille régulièrement les
plages ça c'est juste une petite zone
donc ils viennent avec leur pelle et un
seau et par là c'est une zone beaucoup
plus grande
mais à Antigua cette patrouille de
seulement 30 personnes ne peut
surveiller qu’une douzaine de sites
nous nous assurons tous les jours entre
8h et 16h30 de réduire ce problème
d'extraction de sable
mais c'est en grande partie là le
problème la majorité de l'extraction de
sable a lieu après notre départ la nuit
entre 18h et 6h du matin
désactivez comme Ellie Feller dénonce
l'impunité qui règne à Antigua
cette maison je l'ai vu en vente
8,5 millions de dollars le jardinier a
récupéré du sable à l'autre bout de la
plage pour l'étendre sur les allées de
la maison
c'était il y a 5 jours je les ai vu et
ça arrive souvent ici je vais vous
montrer
les plages d'Antigua ont fait la fortune
de l'île près de 30% de son PIB dépend
du tourisme
Jarvis lit est un ancien footballeur
international depuis sa retraite
sportive il s'est engagé pour la défense
de l'environnement
les plages P les factures à Antigua
c'est triste et malheureux mais sans les
plages Antigua ne seraient plus Antigua
50 km sépare Antigua de Barbuda la
deuxième plus grande île de l'archipel
Barbuda est au cœur des trafics de sable
dans la région ici de véritables mines
opère à une échelle industrielle depuis
les années 70 Barbuda est le réservoir
de sable et Caraïbes en 50 ans ce sont
plusieurs milliards de tonnes de sable
qui ont été extraites
maintenant après que le sable était
extrait la bave vous pouvez voir une des
machines qu'ils utilisent pour extraire
le sable si vous regardez les racines de
ses cocotiers vous pouvez voir jusqu'où
elle est le sable
Washington et biologiste de formation
cette activiste alerte régulièrement sur
les ravages de l'extraction du sable
fois celui qui est assis sur le
bulldozer ne voit que des buissons
arrachés mais une personne comme moi
voit un écosystème en train d'être
détruit la biodiversité est en train de
disparaître par Bouddha est isolé et
peuplé seulement 2600 habitants pour
limiter les dégâts sur l'environnement
le gouvernement local avait décidé de
fermer les sites d'extraction en 2006
mais pour l'île le sable est une source
de revenus essentiels les mines n'ont
jamais fermé les personnes qui gagnent
la majorité de l'argent liée à
l'extraction du sable ce sont celles qui
contrôlent le transport ce sont les
personnes qui contrôlent le marché ou
responsable se vend et à quel prix
tous les jours un balai incessant de
camions transporte le sable vers ce site
de concassage c'est là que le sable sera
raffiné avant d'être exporté à
l'étranger ce marché est estimé à 30
millions d'euros par an oui mais nous
gagnons probablement moins d'un pour
cent mais à la fin nous nous retrouvons
avec la majorité des dégâts
environnementaux et nous devons dépenser
de l'argent pour réparer ses dégâts et
ce n'est pas seulement de l'argent ça a
un impact sur la qualité de
l'environnement sur la santé et le
bien-être de la population les revenus
du sable ne profiteraient qu'à une
infime minorité de la population
pourtant cette industrie risque de
changer irrémédiablement le paysage
d'antigoua et Barbuda
les plages sont en danger si vous
revenez dans 20 ans certaines de ces
plages auront disparu
je n'ai pas encore d'enfants mais
j'aimerais qu'il puisse vivre ce que je
suis en train de vivre vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est carrément déprimant
rien que d'y penser à l'avenir
possible que plus rien de tout ça
n'existe
en mai dernier le gouvernement d'Antigua
et Barbuda a autorisé l'extraction de
plusieurs milliards de tonnes de sable
en haute mer ce sable sera exporté afin
de construire des plages artificielles
dans le monde entier au risque de voir
celle d'Antigua disparaître